hello everyone and welcome to what will
most likely be the shortest video I ever
made it's a game from round seven of the
Batumi chess Olympia 2018 it's the match
Spain versus Algeria
Manuel Paris candelario vs. Ayman Razak
and it's a really really a very short
game but it would be a crime not to show
it as it's very interesting and it
features the Scandinavian which is
something if you remember when we
covered the palma de mer intra zonal by
papi Fisher Fisher didn't consider this
to be a real opening and he smiled when
his opponent played it against him and
it will also make you feel less you know
you want to feel too bad about any
blunder you've ever made as remember
this is a game between two grandmasters
so let's dive straight into it
mono opens with E for and like we've
said we have d5 the Scandinavian defense
he captures on d5 Queen captures on d5
in the night to the c3 so the standard
Scandinavian a Queen to a5 and now
Bishop to c4 and okay we have Knight to
f6 by black d3 we have c6 taking away
the b5 and d5 square from whites night
and here we have Queen to e2 we have
better up to f5 black develops the light
square bishop before closing it with e6
and we have Bishop to d2 by white this
Bishop to d2 it took quite 12 seconds
the plate white is preparing queenside
castle and here you wanna as the bishop
is now eyeing the Queen you want to
retrieve the Queen to c7 or d8 and then
simply continue development for example
neither 397 the game goes on and all is
well but here after this Bishop to d2
move were white prepare the castles
black plate Knight B to d7 and the
Knight B to d7 is a huge blunder that
loses the game and what's more important
black didn't spend like a second to just
play it like it wasn't an automatic
response or anything black actually
spent two and a half minutes on this
move and it's really amazing well played
against the Scandinavian a lot of times
and I also enjoyed playing Scandinavia
myself in tournaments and you know
whenever the
you do have a discovery with this night
you never actually think there are any
good discoveries because in fact there
never are but this is in fact one of the
cases where there is a good discovery so
feel free to pause the video here and
find the move that wins the game for
white immediately so black made a knight
black play Knight bt7 and move seven how
do you win this I'll give it a couple of
seconds for this side as usual so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you have crushed the
Scandinavian defense and proved Bobby
Fischer's point and for those of you who
just wanna enjoy the show Knight d5 and
it's all over the queen is attacked and
you do have to do something about this
there's really no square available for
the Queen due to this a knight bt7 move
and the fact that the Queen hasn't moved
back from this discovery and it's
amazing
black did play a couple of more moves
hoping that you know the internet will
not see this brilliancy do two more
moves being played but you know you
should resign here the game is over and
there's no point in continuing it you
have to move the Queen if you move it to
d8 you get Knights to d6 and this is a
smothered mate you can capture of course
because the pawn is pinned from the
Queen on the other hand if you play
something like Queen to b6 you're
getting Knight d6 check King moves
Knight captures on f7 with check you
move and knight Knight captures on h8
it's a free rook the there's no point in
continuing this capturing on b2 doesn't
really do anything for black and lastly
but not leastly
since you enjoyed that one so much after
night before you can play Queen a4 but
it loses to the same ID and ID 6
checking moves check King moves and
again it's a free rook so there's
nothing to play here you have to resign
here and congratulate your opponent you
know we've just lost in 7 moves to a
grandmaster being a grandmaster yourself
but he did play Queen captures and e2
perhaps hoping for four miracles but we
never know Queen captures and d2 was
played and pawn captures on b5 but
should capture some d5 so you do have
two points for the Queen but by White's
position is much better and you know he
he does have a queen and black
Bishop captures Bishop captures tonight
of three black tried a couple more moves
Bishop c6 Queen to f4 I will have
castles and 95 attacking the bishop
would have captured Sanji to look to g1
and after Bishop to d5 black decided he
will not play this game any longer so in
fact the game did last for 15 moves but
I decided to name it that he lost in 7
moves because indeed he did lose in 7
moves after Knight B to d7 he just you
know kept playing in hopes of the
internet not seeing this brilliancy but
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it very rarely will I show such
a short game but it is a classical time
format game from the Olympiad so I did
feel that you should all see it so I do
hope you enjoyed it as usual you
couldn't check two of my previous videos
you're thankful for watching and we're
gonna I'm continuing on watching the
live coverage of the Olympians 7 so you
know you can do that as well if if you
have the option to do so thank you all
and I'll see you soon and it was Bobby
Fischer right or what about the
Scandinavian see you soon